[music]
Uh welcome everyone and good afternoon.
Um in the next 20 minutes we are going
to talk about something many
organization are facing which is moving
AI from prom promising pilots to real
operational impact. And to this I'm
pleased to have with me Eisenberg, CMO
of Samsara, so global leader uh in um in
fleet safety operation and Eve Pan, you
are the CEO of Fria, the European leader
in vehicle rental for mission critical
services.
So Eve, let's start with you. What uh
convinced you that it was the time to
rethink the way Fria operates? The
inflection point came four years ago
when I started as a CEO and talking with
our customers I realized that their duty
was to keep their fleet running day and
night to ensure the uptime of uh
critical hidden infrastructure in urban
area and that's where I got the light
and I discovered that those vehicles
were used as production units on wheel
and that changed completely the way you
take decision and that's where I
realized that Uh it was completely
different than just renting those assets
and um we had to move from just managing
those vehicles to become really in a um
critical
infrastructure platform to to provide
customers the full um added value they
were searching for.
>> Very interesting. Miguel and I'm turning
to you. Uh so we hear a lot about AI
pilots. uh why scaling AI is so
difficult and how do you help your
customer to make that leap?
>> Yeah, so if you think about it with
Frighten, they have 11,000 customers,
52,000 fleets that they manage. So
imagine going from a pilot of AI of 50
and rolling that out to 52,000. Uh so it
was really critical to align on what our
goals were and how do we get to ROI very
quickly. And so amazing enough they're
already seeing uh total cost of
ownership reduction by 20% 98% vehicle
uptime and then 10% operational yield
and I think that's only the beginning
when you're applying AI to all of this.
The other thing is a standardized
architecture. If you think about it, uh
they have all different types of
vehicles and as they grow through maybe
autonomous or robotics or humanoid
vehicles, so a mixed autonomy fleet.
They need to be able to bring all that
data into one platform. And then also
they need to have a robust
infrastructure that's an open platform.
And so we have APIs that hook into their
Nexa platform so they can really uh get
the most out of the data, understand
maintenance. Uh you know, fuel is a big
deal right now. So, how do they
understand their idle time, their fuel
usage, all of that? And then, of course,
the success matters on implementation
and being able to implement very
quickly. So, less than 15 minutes per
vehicle as you're bringing those in and
taking them out of rotation because of
course any downtime costs money.
>> Yes.
>> Impressive. Um, Eve, let's talk about
people.
>> Uh, because technology is one thing, but
getting people on board is another
thing. Uh so what did you learn from
bringing thousands of drivers and
clients uh through this change?
>> Very good question by the way. Once we
learn a lot first what we learn
it's also about technology. So having
like Megan said 52,000 vehicles across
nine countries and 11,000 customers
across six different uh mission critical
end sectors in urban areas. It's very
difficult for us and it was a challenge
to capture the data from every vehicle
because without data no fitting for AI
and no feedback loop to our customers.
So we searched for a partner which we
find Samsara. We had already previously
some partners that we kicked out because
they were not innovative enough and we
searched for a partner that we found
that um well had uh the same mindset as
Freken. And once we had that plat that
technology on telematic we launch a
project across the company and um we
started small we convinced people we
made many mistakes. We also deliver
tangible results to our customers to our
employees and uh you know in the end uh
it and um real data
um
shouldn't be seen as I uh I mean I would
say AI and real-time data shouldn't be
seen as an IT project but it's a
transformation foundation of our our
model.
So people really engage with that
transformation.
>> Absolutely. This is crucial in any
organization I guess.
>> Um I'm turning back to you Megan. Um so
you are working for thousands of
organization across the world. Um once
customer start seeing their fleet data.
>> Yes.
>> Um what's the insight safety efficiency
other? What's the insight that surprised
them the most?
>> Yeah, there's certainly some aha moments
if you think about having visibility
into drivers and vehicles. uh and what
we call harsh events. So accidents or
avoiding accidents. And so those are
definitely eyeopening. And what does
that lead to? Well, uh when you're
running this large of a fleet operation,
you need to be able to coach drivers. Uh
and how do you figure that out if you
have all of these different drivers
where you focus? Because these uh the
operators, you maybe have a dozen, but
you you can't scale without uh AI. So AI
helps you scale infinitely. And so the
coaching agent one will detect who needs
coaching. Maybe they're newer drivers or
maybe they're uh more prone to accidents
or having accidents. So you can focus on
that. But now they have co-pilots. So if
you think about it, you have a new
driver or every year or so you want to
do a a drivealong or ride along. How do
you do that at scale? Well, agents can
actually now ride along with the drivers
and coach in real time. And and you
really want to bring your coaching team
and your drivers together. And so uh it
allows them to focus where they need to
focus uh and prove actually most drivers
are really really quite good. So you can
also celebrate the good drivers and and
have that access to that data.
>> Absolutely. Um back to you. Let's talk
about business impact. So you are the
CEO of the company. So from your co
perspective, how do you know that your
safety program is working and what has
it changed for your customer? How do you
measure that?
>> Again, a very good question. Uh safety
in our business is a matter of trust.
Our customer want safe operation. They
want efficient operation in urban areas
and they need a comprehensive set of
data that we can provide to them. Um
and it's the uh behavior of the asset,
the vehicle, it's the behavior of the
driver. It's the the data we can collect
as well from the environment. And the
capability we have now to feedback them
with all this data is very crucial. uh
more specifically on safety in the early
days already one or two years ago with
Samsara we were partnering on about 1500
cams in vehicles in the UK because what
you can see in Europe is that Europe
legislation is different between the UK
and the rest of continental Europe and
uh so we have advanced experience there
with 1,500 vehicles and very positive
feedback from our customers the fleet
operators because they can feedback
their driver and improve their behavior.
So it's very tangible results and uh
based on that very positive experience
we decided to roll out this in the rest
of Europe. Uh in order to achieve that
we first had to go to get GDPR compliant
in France but also in other European
countries and there Samsara supported us
quite a lot. So thanks for that. You're
>> welcome. And on top of that, we rolled
out and we set up a uh digital
intelligent platform called Nexa to be
able to pass to customers our fleet
operators um the data including all the
data from um uh CAM that I embark on
each vehicle. So we uh in France we
start about one month ago with 500
drivers that are equipped with CAM and
we are currently doing a PC with them.
Thank you.
>> Um let's now move to maintenance
>> and more specifically to predictive
maintenance. Yes.
>> So keeping in mind that fleets around
the world are getting more and more
complex evolving in a mixed autonomy
energy world. Um Megan, where do you see
AI making the biggest difference over
the few next years? Yeah. So, it's a
really big deal in maintenance and to
your point, it's uh not only predictive,
but it's preventative because you
imagine if you have a maintenance issue
on the road, that quickly becomes a
safety incident. And so, the future of
it, uh, when you have drivers, they may
detect a error code on the engine, they
may call the shop, let them know, then
you have to put the work order through
and then bring the the actual vehicle
in. And now imagine if with autonomous
vehicles um or any mixed humanoid
robotics etc. they may not detect that.
So of course you have to collect that
information through telematics maybe
visual through camera and then act on
that. Now with agents we can do that and
we can scale that across 52,000.
And so what happens now uh the Telmatics
AI agent will detect the error code.
We'll automatically create the work
order. We'll automatically uh ship the
part. So, it'll get the part. It'll know
when the part's going to arrive. So,
it'll uh change navigation and update
your routing plan. So, maybe it's the
next day or two days later, you'll know
that you need to take it to the
workshop, they'll go ahead and fix it.
And you take the human out of that. And
think about that, you compress the
timeline so much. And so, you're it's
not just marginally making it more
efficient. It's dramatically changing
the workflows and who needs to be
involved. And I I think it's really
interesting if you think about it.
Traditional SAS software doesn't really
have an opinion. You're creating a
dashboard. You create a workflow. It's
hardcoded. Uh and a human has to go
check that, make a decision, and act.
Well, with AI, it's more opinionated. So
AI has opinions. It can take action. And
so it can actually dramatically change
workflow. It could save money, lowers
the total cost of ownership, creates a
better yield. And so we're dramatically
transforming uh what we see in the real
physical world. Uh and you can do that
whether it's with a driver, without a
driver, with robots. And as you know,
you see all these robots on the floor
and how we're coordinating that. Well,
you need a central system that does that
where agents can look at all of that
data. So if we have, you know, tons,
trillions and trillions of data points
that we're bringing together uh for the
physical world uh with agents, we could
do that so much faster now.
>> Absolutely. A huge evolution. Um, Eve,
>> uh, with such a big fleet at FEA, I
think we're speaking about 60,000
vehicles in Europe, um, maintenance is
not just keeping vehicle running. Uh, it
is also about safety, safety of the
drivers, of the customer, but also the
public in the in the public area. Do you
have um a concrete real example where
predictive maintenance helped improve
safe safety and or reduce risk? I don't
have one. I have thousand of them. Uh
first preventive maintenance is a key
disruptive element in our industry for
two things. First maintenance is our
second cost line in our P&L and is the
first benefit for our customer is uh
lower VR vehicle of road. Combining the
two is essential for our industry. Um so
a few months ago we uh we set up a uh FA
intelligent operation um
self-improvement layer which scan um
every seconds the entire fleet of 60,000
vehicles across Europe and detect early
signs of potential future failure and we
feed back uh those signals to 250
workshops spread across Europe and by
anticipation we avoid major failures.
And uh what we see actually I was very
afraid that within the supply chain or
within the organization
u our colleagues our employee would not
understand this change and they actually
they discovered the benefit of it
because they're able to call the
customer the driver ask to come to the
branch they have a quick repair instead
of managing an emergency and um we are
improving the VR of the fleet operator.
So it's a win-win win-win as many time
as you want and actually we have about
90% accuracy on the predictability of uh
the information we get and we are aiming
to reduce our unscheduled M&R that
represent about 40% of our total by
approximately 40%. So that's very
encouraging and very disruptive and we
are the first one to do it.
>> That's amazing.
>> Very interesting example indeed. Yeah.
Um, Megan, one question for you. Um,
regarding Samsara, who announced
recently several new AI products, um,
Agent Studio, tracking label, I think.
Which one, um, for you is the most
exciting and why?
>> Well, I have a little show and tell, so
I'm going to have to talk about tracking
labels, but the agent code, uh, agent
codes are pretty cool because we put in
the hands of our operators, they can
build their own agents on their own data
with their fleets. So, I think there's a
lot of uh goodness there, but I want to
talk a little bit about tracking labels.
When I think about all the robots that
are out there, all the mixed autonomy
things. Um, two years ago, uh, we
launched something called the asset tag.
Uh, this has a six-year battery. Uh, and
you can put on very expensive assets and
you can put it anywhere. It hooks in.
Once the battery is gone, you dispose of
it. You know, not it's great. Well, our
customers of course said this is not big
enough. or is not small enough I should
say and so we released what we call the
excess very you know small and think
about it you have hand tools all those
different things that you might want to
put out there we track it but then of
course this was maybe two quarters ago
our customer said we really need
something that is much smaller it has to
be uh disposable so you have to be able
to throw it away for packages and it has
to be cheap and so it took us a little
bit but this is actually a tracking
label. You would print it out in a
printer. You stick it on your package
and it the it's got blue uh Bluetooth
technology in it. And so it lasts for 60
days. And imagine now all you're
tracking a pallet, you're tracking
pharmaceuticals, you're tracking really
anything. Uh and it's unlike anything.
And because we have a network all around
the world, you can track things in
seconds. So it's like a industrial Apple
tag if you think about it. And so this
is transformational and you can only do
this if you have a network. You think
about RFID is very expensive. Even
cellular is expensive. So how do you get
something under a dollar that you can
put on on your cargo? And then if I
think about it when packages come in to
the US maybe DHL comes in, it goes to
Memphis. Then the next time you see it,
it might be Chicago and then San
Francisco. I live in San Francisco. and
then the last mile I might see it on the
truck. Well, if I put a label on it, I
can see it everywhere along the journey.
And I think one of the things we deal
with is cargo theft, uh, vehicle theft,
anything, packages all the time. And
this is a great way to to really look at
that. And it's only possible because of
AI and the amount of data uh, that we
collect and are able to quickly get
through. And agents can detect if it
goes off path. It can let customers know
when it's coming. all these things that
would take a lot of phone calls can now
be done by agents and so it's I think
it's really cool uh to see what our
customers will do with it next.
>> Yeah, very impressive innovation.
>> Um to finish I have a common question
for you both uh looking ahead in three,
four, five years from now what will be a
best-in-class fleet operation look like?
You want to start?
>> I would say ladies first.
>> Okay. Okay. I'm happy to start with
that. I mean I I think it's that idea
that it yes it's interesting if you
marginally improve efficiencies using
agents but if you transform your entire
workflow like that world where uh the
car has an issue it automatically routes
the workflow orders the part reschedules
I think that's the new world if you
think about construction sites where
you're going to have humans and robots
and vehicles and heavy equipment all of
that uh all coming together how do you
do it the most efficient Okay. Well,
agents and AI are going to coordinate
that. So, as I'm building something,
it's going to know when the parts coming
in. It's going to know when someone
needs to come out and and authenticate
it. It's going to have the robot show up
with the heavy equipment. That world
will operate in just in time. I spent
some time in Japan learning a lot about
manufacturing. And you think about
manufacturing floor, it's everything
arriving at the right time. Well, the
future uh really physical AI is
everything we need arriving exactly at
the right time. So we're not wasting
fuel. We're not waiting. There's no idle
time. Human time is valuable. We don't
want to waste people's time waiting. Uh
and we'll be able to build things much
faster and we'll be able to coordinate
this mixed autonomy world much better.
>> Thank you. Well, we're running out of
time. I'm sure you agree with me again.
You really agree? [laughter]
>> So, thank you very much and thank you
very much to everyone for your
attention. Okay. Thank you. Bye-bye.